OK.
I want to show you
the new emulation
feature in Chrome DevTools.
And it's great for understanding
how your content's going
to look across
different devices.
So I'm going to start here
on the Wikipedia site.
And you can see when I
resize the site down,
that it doesn't scale well.
I don't get any sense of
how this site would play out
if I were viewing it on
a phone, for example.
So if I open up DevTools,
and I bring the console using
the Escape key on the
keyboard-- and you can also
use this icon up
here-- you'll see
that there's a new
tab called Emulation.
Now there are lots of
really interesting things
inside of here, like screen
resolution, device pixel ratio,
user agent strings, and other
fun stuff like geolocation.
Now Emulation is going to let
me set all of these things
individually and have total
control over how Chrome's
going to present itself
to any given site.
But to make life a
little bit easier,
we've also included a
bunch of device presets.
So I'm going to go ahead
and choose the Nexus 4 here.
Now that sets a bunch
of these features
on, which you can see now have
this blue check next to them.
Because the Wikipedia
site actually
serves different content
to mobile devices,
I'm going to need
to refresh the page.
And now you'll see that
we're served the mobile site.
Now we've done a bunch
of work to make sure
that the Emulation behaves as
close to reality as possible.
And one of the things
you're going to notice
is that my cursor has
turned into this dot.
And that's because
we're emulating
touch, including
proper touch events.
If I hold Shift and
click Drag, you'll
see that I'm also able
to mimic pinch to zoom.
This whole experience
is far better
than simply spoofing
the user agent string.
You can really start
to get a sense of how
your project's going to
react for any given device.
I also want to
show you this demo
to give you a bit more
detail on device pixel ratio.
You'll see that my desktop has
a device pixel ratio of one.
And if we take a peek
at the source file,
you'll see that
we're using image-set
to choose the most
appropriate image.
Right now, that's the 1x image.
If I turn on Emulation
inside of Dev Tools
and set the device
pixel ratio to 2,
you'll see that we're
now serving the 2x image.
This is super useful
when you're looking
to test serving the right assets
based on device pixel ratio,
whether you have access to
a high DPI device or not.
So that's just a taste of
emulating mobile devices.
Please take a look around,
use it in your workflow,
and head to devtools.chrome.com
to learn more.